I have this tweet from kim.com he
tweeted this video from Russian American
Daily Russian defense minister NATO
assembled 360
000 troops in eastern Europe Poland is
preparing to occupy Western Ukraine this
is the perspective of Russia
in calm wrong and calm lies you call
propaganda call it whatever you want but
we do know that Poland is sending
another 2 000 troops to reinforce this
border with Belarus we do know that Joe
Biden is calling Reserve forces I
already did to be deployed into Europe
and there is a very real concern Chinese
and Russian warships conduct highly
provocative drills near Alaska that uh I
don't know World War III so take your
pick there's good reason for China to be
attacking us from the inside to
destabilize the United States and
there's a very real possibility that
we're about to escalate into World War
III I say about to but who knows how
long this stuff takes you know it could
take several years or it could be
overnight I feel like it's you know you
have become famous for calling for for I
not World War III I guess Civil War is
normally before he just mentioned I'm
sorry I apologize just occasionally
calling out the words for saying the
phrase but I think again with the
presence of military ships I mentioned
this um I think last week that you know
we have this newly commissioned ship the
Canterbury that's in Australia I think
now more than ever we are seeing this
sort of toe-to-toe escalation in in a
small way it's just hard for me to see
who is going to make that first a truly
aggressive move and I think
that's the worst part of War because
we'll look back and be able to say like
oh well this was happening for a long
time but right now we're all sort of
saying like is this it is this happening
and I think China feels very emboldened
to threaten Taiwan for instance when
they look at Joe Biden you know he
doesn't know where he's going he's
falling down all the time and they look
at the breakdown of American society
which in part is thanks to them with you
know Tick Tock and they're pushed a week
in America so you know China is
emboldened I think they feel they can
take Taiwan and America won't respond
because we've seen you know so many red
lines across like in Syria when the red
line was crossed with chemical weapons
and Obama threatened to do something but
he didn't
um you know we've seen things in Ukraine
as well so I think China is moving
closer and closer and you have to think
as well China has huge investments in
African countries
um they have that Island what's that
island called Diego Garcia which I
believe is owned by the UK they're
actually giving that back to I believe
it's Mauritius so China could
potentially take that as a base
um in the Pacific so you see China's
building the military they're building
the islands and we're when they look at
America and they see you know Joe Biden
a nation in Decline it just emboldens
them let's get conspiratorial we have
this big fire in Maui they don't know
how it started wow I'm sure it's going
to turn out to be like someone's cow
kicked over a lantern or something like
that to be to be honest however we do
have this story from back in February
China flashed mysterious Green Lasers
over Hawaii NASA says you guys remember
this this is the first thing I thought
of when like you have these lasers guide
barcode yeah wow and uh why by the way
and what look at that yo look at this
video
the light and on fire with that
language
look at that my bad what are they doing
with these beams of lasers
being fired over Hawaii they're either
Purdue they're producing heat because
that's what lasers are they're either
doing illumination or targeting scanning
or heating yeah scanning Maybe
and you you can if you notice you can
only see the lasers in certain points
I don't believe that China intended for
these lasers to be seen something
particulate matter causes refraction
allowing you to see the lasers in in the
air
um maybe we haven't followed up in the
story maybe there was an answer as to
what this was they say China's most
likely behind the mysterious lights
Chinese pollution monitoring satellite
daki 1 probably produced the light
spotted over Hawaii
oh so it's monitoring pollution oh you
can call whatever you want but my
attitude is you look we are not we are
not on good terms with China right now I
mean we can we can pretend oh no trade's
going on everything's like no come on
they want Taiwan they're building up
their military there's a chance for
escalation a chance for conflict they
want the South China Sea and then
they've got ships with Russia coming
near the Illusions coming near U.S
territory going near Hawaii and then
they're pulling off something like this
so look how hard is it to start a fire
it's ridiculously easy to start a fire
and they can fire lasers okay
it's a little challenging to get the
fire to spread but there were hurricane
level it said it was like hurricane
level winds or there's I don't I don't I
don't have high winds if they can start
50 fires what all at once with the
sequence of satellites doing High burst
high energy laser lasers then getting
fire to spread isn't really the issue
because you make the fire instantly in a
bunch of different places and they can
monitor the weather in Hawaii I mean you
could just Google that like what I was
reading from the national Guardsman
who's making a statement was that you
know there's low humidity and high winds
so that's perfect conditions for
wildfires to spread which means any
arson fires would also spread as quickly
like China is perfectly able to say like
this happens to be a dangerous period
for fire in Hawaii perhaps now if if
they were to do something uh there was
also a Chinese balloon observed in
Internet above international waters near
Hawaii February 2022. wow all right
right yeah yeah so it does seem like
obviously they have they have a targeted
interest in Hawaii uh and remember when
Marjorie Taylor green argued that there
were like space lasers that could start
fires maybe she was right I think it's
really funny because they claimed she
said Jewish space lasers when she
mentioned like a Rothschild's Bank was
providing funding for certain technology
or whatever and I'm like well I don't
know about any of that but I can tell
you that we have video of lasers being
fired from satellites their argument
came from a pollution monitoring
satellite but lasers did come from this
this satellite now I don't know the
capabilities of this but uh
I'm not gonna believe them right I'm not
gonna believe Chinese languages we're
looking for pollution in Hawaii well and
they said the balloon that went over
Montana was like oh it was monitoring
the weather and it blew off course and
we didn't say anything like so I don't
want to be too mean to China right now
but they lie I mean they're declining to
meet with our secretary of state or
there are any delegations for like from
Anton Anthony blink blinken so what
makes us think that they're feeling like
they should give us any honest
information right I think I think
Ollie's right there is a there is a
uh General opinion coming from China
that America is not in a position of
strength I mean I remember being on pop
culture at the end the pop culture
crisis the podcast uh at the end of this
last year and uh we were talking about
the fact that China was declining more
western movies I mean they are not
interested in American culture right now
and in fact to your point they're
probably trying to insulate themselves
from American culture because American
culture uh modern American culture is
largely about the destruction and the
Turning within oneself and there's no
page there's a lack of Civic engagement
it makes the country weak and so in turn
it makes their adversaries uh Stronger
they're saying that it may have been
Cloud aerosol lidar and infrared
Pathfinder satellite observation Calypso
good job with that one guys path it's
been orbiting for more than 15 years so
maybe it's nothing but I can tell you
this space lasers are real
confirmed we know Popular Mechanics we
know about space lasers lasers can start
fires the question is would it what is
the potentiality for China to have any
kind of of laser on a satellite that can
produce enough energy to start a fire
would they do it against us I think this
is all easily within the realm of
possibility that they can damage our
economy and Us in major areas
and make it look like an accident
it's uh I guess fifth generational
Warfare yeah first thought I had was
let's get cash Patel in here and talk
about high-tech weaponry and see what
he's not going to tell everyone what the
American government has necessarily but
he'll be able to smile and Nod while
we're talking about these things hey man
that's it if we need to be on guard I I
don't say
believe everything or have an open mind
to the point where your brain falls out
like not everything is possible
everything's possible well I love that
image your mind is so open your brain
Falls have you ever seen it's a meme I
didn't make it up but there's like a me
but the guys thinking and then it thinks
yeah
um keep it in mind though yeah space
lasers are legit real and they can make
things very very hot I think the
question is
what's the point of the timing like at
what point do we think that anyone would
want yeah just chaos well I mean if if
if if we're busy dealing with if China
China invades Taiwan tomorrow then we'll
get it right so this is this is a target
this is a a Pacific
economic Hub and Naval bases and they
just did military training the Chinese
and Russians a few days ago up by the
Aleutian Islands right and the U.S
deployed warships and now all of a
sudden unknown fire Sparks and wipes out
a whole city I mean the damage that we
see in this city Only 53 dead thank
heavens because it was just a fire
but this wiped out basically the whole
city that's a if if that is a weapon
that is a powerful weapon
God like dude it the reality is we've
got videos online of the us having large
infrared lasers
that can shoot down drones it Heats them
up until they burst into flames and then
they fall out of the sky
with a satellite
I don't know how long it would take to
to get a charge for a laser powerful
enough to start to start a fire but you
don't I mean the range is probably the
issue I mean we're talking was it 50
miles what what's uh what's a what's a
low earth orbit satellite probably 150
miles someone you want to go back real
quick
that's a long distance for something to
start to fire so I I don't know it seems
that seems like a bit much to be
completely honest uh your own Theory
right now between 160 kilometers and 2
000 kilometers wow so even less than
that so right so it could be like 60
miles 70 miles
can is there a laser that can start a
fire within 60 miles I kind of feel like
military attack is well like Way Beyond
what we think and even if it was like a
rail gun that launched a small
incendiary or something it's easier than
or like 10 lasers to like times ten if
you can if for the distance right made
it hotter and focusing in One Direction
the question is how much energy would
need to to store and be able to pull
something like that at that range and it
may be maybe it takes seven months to
charge up with solar and then it can set
off a couple small fires something who
knows but you all you got this you also
got the fires up in Canada yeah so
what's what's going on now they're going
to claim climate change and all that
stuff I'm sure but what if the reality
is war
well there was um wildfires in Greece
recently and um some investigative
reporters found that the land that was
burnt was already had a permit to build
wind farms but the locals didn't want
them to build there so that could be one
explanation that's it's purposeful arson
so that land developers can buy the land
cheap and get in there and you know and
clip claim it's climate change but
really it's just them trying to see some
land for a cheap price thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time